the media shy illega Rinat Akhmetov and
his company hide behind the barricades
he has his headquarters near
Independence Square in Kiev he doesn't
give interviews these images of the
oligarch visiting one of his steel works
in eastern Ukraine come from his public
relations office Akhmatova
is said to be the richest man in Ukraine
with assets worth about eight and a half
billion euros the oligarch owns mines
and steel factories in the creevy rock
region Andrey Levitsky runs them he owes
a lot to Akhmetov from being a simple
train driver he's risen to being a
director in charge of more than 8,000
employees
iron ore pellets are produced here
they are sold around the world
especially to China
for us this iron ore concentrate is what
oil is for Russia but for two years the
raw material has plummeted in value the
director admits the plant isn't making
as much profit maintaining the aging
equipment is expensive
everywhere there are maid shift repairs
but that's not what the director wants
to show us he prefers to take us into
the new computer room the factory is
monitored and runs from here it's
increased the old plants efficiency the
former command system in the mine has
been replaced by teamwork the iron ore
comes from deposits 450 meters
underground there are enough supplies
here to last for the next 50 years with
wages equivalent to about 800 euros a
month the truck drivers are among the
top earners the question of how the
oligarch came to own the mines doesn't
interest anyone here
exclaiming oh my oh bucket I mean what
do I think about Madoff he's a man who
is purposeful does his work
professionally he's developing his
business and increasing his profits
shall swing the hoard almost the entire
region depends on the mine and on Rinat
Akhmetov the workers live in houses that
belong to the mine the mine pays their
health insurance and even gives them
holiday pay Andre Levitsky insists on
showing us the factory's own cultural
center with a mining museum just one of
the oligarchs many charitable activities
parents can show their children and
grandchildren where they'll be working
in our factory in the future economist
Igor burakov ski on the other hand says
the oligarch economy is shaky at present
Akhmatova is losing a lot of money the
tax breaks he's had on till now are no
longer valid under the new ukrainian
President his factories in eastern
Ukraine are under fire terror attack in
the companies will be stealing cars
different well pieces of equipment will
they trying well to frighten the people
not to let them to go well to the to the
place of work and all together it makes
whites well unpleasant situation for the
business from one side in the short run
but from the other side it's still
unclear well for the people likely not
acne at all what would be the
medium-term and long-term implications
of the current situation director andrey
Levitsky says the unrest has not yet
affected his factory but the fighting is
only a few hundred kilometers from the
plan skates
he hopes everything there remains quiet
you